so you mentioned the importance of trust
at the very beginning of the
conversation uh from The Outsider
perspective just a maybe a dark question
which is like how much trust is there in
Washington how how much the flip side of
that how much backstabbing is there can
you form like long-term relationships
with
people on a basic human level where you
know you're not going to be betrayed
screwed over manipulated for again going
back to the old money and
power the answer is yes and the answer
is no so I I made some incredible
friends lifelong friends through my time
in Washington but the way I I I think
about it from politics I think in
geopolitics as well is I would say that
politicians really don't have friends
politicians have interests and as long
as you kind of Follow that rule you you
should be able to know how to rate where
your relationship with a given person
falls in the Spectrum but I do think I
was the exception I I did make some
tremendous friends and again i' go back
to what I said about negotiation where
you know when you're in a situation
where there's really nothing in it for
any of you personally but you're in a
fox all together and nobody in
Washington can get anything done by
themselves you have people coming from
all different backgrounds all different
experiences all different geography
coming together agreeing on an objective
creating a plan and then every day
rowing together in order to get it done
it's a beautiful thing and you really
learn what people are about and so when
you go through an experience like that
you learn who's in it for themselves you
learn who's in it for the cause and you
know for every you know thing you read
about in The Press of a fight I had with
somebody because we were at odds you
know I have about you know 100 people
who have become lifelong friends because
I respect the way that when we were
under Fire together they got better they
were competent and they were there to
serve for the right reason and so uh so
I guess the answer is yes it it it is it
is possible you have to be careful
because there are a lot of Mercurial
people there I always say the
politicians are like Gladiators um I
didn't have as much respect for
politicians till I got there but if you
think about it everyone who's got a
congressional seat or a senate seat
there's 25 people back at home who want
their job who think they're smarter than
them who are trying to backstab them and
so I always say that the political d
damic it's like in the private sector
you're standing on on flat ground you
choose which fights you take on when you
take them on how you fight them in
politics it's like you're standing on a
ball and what you have to realize is
that there's maybe like 10 things that
you have to do but there's a potential
cost to taking on each one that might
destabilize you you fall off the ball
and then you lose your opportunity to
pursue those you have to always be kind
of marking everything to Market and
going through your calculations to make
sure you can accomplish what you want to
without falling off the ball and losing
your opportunity to make a difference I
guess people like
power and I just feel like to be a good
politician you should be willing like
good meaning good for Humanity be
willing to let go of
power you know try to do the right thing
if there's somebody back home that does
manipulate of stuff screws you over and
takes power from you it's okay I feel
like that kind
of
humility is is required to be a great
leader and I feel like that's actually a
good way to have long-term power because
karma has a viral aspect to it just
doing good by others I feel like is uh
I'd like to say that's true Lex I I
think it's just way more complicated I
mean you look what happened this week
with with Kevin McCarthy right he did
what he thought was morally right um he
thought you know he did a bipartisan
deal uh he was told that you know they
would have his back and then the moment
things got tough they they cut him loose
so again I don't know if that's that's
if that was the right thing or the wrong
thing right I've also seen leaders on
the other end say I'm going to do things
that are shortterm more selfish but the
way they justify to themselves is to say
I believe that my staying in power is
existential to the greater good so I
will do things that maybe are not in the
greater good now because I believe that
my main maining power is and so it's
it's complicated I in an idealized World
I'd love to believe that's the case but
it's just way more complicated than that
yeah I wish it wasn't but it is yeah
maybe I I do just wish people zoomed out
people in politics zoomed out a bit and
just asked themselves what are we all
doing this for you know like sometimes
you can get like a little bit lost in
the game of it if you zoom out you
realize like Integrity is way more
important than like little gains in
money or little gains in power in the
long term just when you look at yourself
in the mirror at the end of the day and
also how history remembers you I just
feel like people do some dark stuff when
they're like in that moment when they're
losing power and they try to hold on a
little too hard mhm this is when this is
when they can do really dark things like
bring out the worst in themselves
and it's just sad to see it I wish there
was a kind of Machinery of government
would inspire people to be their best
selves in their last days versus the
worst selves right when that system gets
invented you know you'll you'll share
with me what it is but it's a look let
me give you another way to frame it
which is and this was kind of the the
revelation we spoke before about you
know kind of when I was getting my butt
kicked by the russan investigation and
all the different areas but kind of the
basic framework I looked at was I said
okay you know this all feels tough but I
said the game's the game The Game's been
here you know way longer you know way
before I came and it'll be here way long
after I leave and so I have two choices
I can complain that the game's tough
it's not fair it's not moral or I can go
and I can try to play the game as hard
as possible and I think that there's two
different things right you have people
who are willing to kind of sit in the
stands and they're willing to yell at
the Players
or make their their their points known
or you have people who are willing to
suit up and get in the arena and go play
and um I have a lot of respect for the
people who who suit up and go play and
and again some of them you know I wish
they would play for different means but
the fact that they're willing to put
their name on the ballot make the
sacrifice and go put on the pads and get
hit and hit others I I think that you
need those people and I wish more people
who had maybe the moral wiring that you
discussed would be putting on a helmet
and go into play cuz it's hard it's hard
I agree with you I just would love to
fix the aspect of the the Russia
collusion accusation the virality the
power of that that's a really
discouraging thing for for people maybe
it's the way it has to be but it's it it
seems like a disincentive to people uh
to participate it it is but I'll give
you again an optimistic side of it is
that you know what you're seeing now
with social media is I do think with
what's Happ happening at X there is now
more of a reversion towards more
egalitarian right and egalitarianism of
information and so for many years the
media Publications were the gate holders
they were The Gatekeepers and then you
had these social media companies that
grew they became so powerful but then
they were tilting the scales why they
were doing it you know we can go through
long explanations for that but if there
truly is a real forum and a
democratization of of information then
you would think that the marketplace of
ideas would surface the real ones and
discredit the non-real ones and I think
that as a society we're starting to kind
of come to grips with the fact that the
power Dynamic is changing and that some
of these institutions that we used to
have a lot of faith in don't deserve our
faith and some of them you know will
actually reform and maybe rearn our
faith so I think that there there there
could be an optimistic tone again the
the years of trump I think that you know
he was an
outsider and you know he represented
something that was existential for the
to the system right you think about for
the 30 years before you were either part
of you know the Clinton Dynasty or the
bush Dynasty I think a lot of people in
the country felt like that whole class
whether you wearing a red shirt or a
blue shirt wasn't representing them and
Trump represented a true Outsider to
that system and I do think that as he
went in there there was a lot of norms
that were broken to try to stop him from
changing the traditional power structure
so I think that we're at a time where
maybe there will be an optimistic
breakthrough where you'll have
institutions that will allow for a lot
more transparency into what truth really
is